ja und das liebe zuschauer hier ist
oksana romberg eine promi kosmetikerin
aus berlin sie hat die schönen der
schönen der hauptstadt noch schöner
gemacht zumindest in deren augen lippen
voller stirn glatter doch dann die
schock nachricht auch für ihre bekannten
patienten oxana wird tot in ihrer
wohnung am kurfürstendamm gefunden die
ermittler die tappen lange zeit im
dunkeln wer hat das getan und vor allem
warum musste sie sterben ja und dann
taucht ganz plötzlich ein video auf das
einen mann zeigt der täter stefan xander
und maximilian kiewel mit exklusiven
recherchen
warum musste oksana romberg kurz vor
ostern dieses jahres sterben prominente
freunde und bekannte sind noch immer
geschafft erstmal war bei mir alles so
leer weil ich eigentlich noch nie
jemanden durch den mord verloren habe so
in meinem leben den ich gut kannte und
weil das ist ja das schrecklichste was
passieren kann also am morgen und dann
hast du noch dazu jemandem bezug dass
das kannte ich vorher gar nicht und das
war alles so surreal
puh das war in berlin ich meinen oxana
war eine erfolgreiche heilpraktikerin
war immer super lieb freundlich hatte
ein tolles geschäft am laufen und auf
einmal zieht wird ermordet ist es her
dass ging erstmal gar nicht in meinen
kopf rein also ich behalte sie als
lebenslustig in erinnerung sie war immer
gut drauf und hatte immer spaß mit ihr
wenn man sie getroffen hat also ich hab
sie nicht schlecht drauf erlebt sie war
immer wird sich laut positiven sinne
also wirklich immer sehr positiver
mensch noch immer scheint es keine heiße
spur im mordfall oxana homberg zu geben
die 50-jährige behandelte in ihrem
schönheitssalon am walter benjamin platz
in berlin charlottenburg seit jahren
ihre kunden mit faltenunterspritzung
botox behandlungen und augenbrauen
korrekturen viele berliner promis gingen
bei ihr ein und aus
dann am ersten april die schock
nachricht von der ermordung oksanas in
ihrer eigenen wohnung ist dass ihr
mörder mit diesen überwachungsvideo
fahndet die polizei nach einem
verdächtigen
diese überwachungskamera filmte den
entscheidenden moment der moment wo der
mutmaßliche mörder von exane romberg
hier in diesem innenhof unterwegs war
das video womit eben die polizei jetzt
nach diesem mann fahndet und sucht warum
ist dieses video auch so brisant weil
wir hier in einem innenhof sind und dort
hinten da war eben der laden das
geschäft von oxana romberg und der
mutmaßliche mörder der war also hier
unterwegs und hat dann nachdem er hier
eine runde gedreht hat dort den ausgang
genommen und ist womöglich oxana
hinterhergelaufen
zuletzt wurde ob seiner romberg am 31
märz gegen 18 uhr gesehen als sie sich
auf den weg nach hause am kurfürstendamm
61 machte für die strecke braucht sie
circa zwei minuten so die polizei waren
sie allerdings in ihrer wohnung ankamen
und ob sie zuvor noch an einem anderen
ort war ist nicht bekannt
diese schritte hier diesen gang den muss
auch der mörder von oxana romberg
gegangen sein denn am ende dieses ganges
da ist die wohnungstür zur wohnung von
oxana romberg und was diesen fall so
zusätzlich dramatisch macht die polizei
hat hier keine einbruchspuren gefunden
das heißt oxana die kannte den mann hat
ihn hereingebeten und hinter dieser tür
da hat sich dann die bluttat dieses
verbrechen abgespielt da war auf einmal
total für polizei und hat nur die natur
irgendwas ist da passiert was kennt man
nicht dass da so viel los ist und dann
war das ja auch schon minuten später auf
social media und das hatte ich ja
wirklich absolut schnell herumgesprochen
und
ja da habe ich dann davon erfahren und
konnte es aber erst gar nicht glauben
weil ich kannte so was nicht also wir
wissen alle das ist leider wurde gibt
auf der welt aber es ist dann einfach
was ganz anderes andere sender zu fünf
minuten weiter entfernt passiert und
dann noch mit dem mann mit dem mann
zusammen gearbeitet hat die ermittler
der berliner mordkommission haben
folgende fragen wer kennt die person auf
dem überwachungsvideo und kann angaben
zu ihrer identität machen er kann
darüber hinaus angaben zur tat oder zum
tatmotiv machen und wer hat frau romberg
noch am mittwoch den 31 märz nach 18 uhr
gesehen oder gesprochen
auch den promi freundin ist es ein
großes anliegen dass der täter gefasst
wird ich habe es dann kann man zur ruhe
kommen wenn man wirklich weiß okay es
ist aufgeklärt dass man auch weiß warum
überhaupt das ist absolut wichtig aber
ich glaube ganz fest daran dass man auch
den mörder finden wird also ich glaube
das ist ein super wichtig ist dass der
mörder gefasst wird einfach dass dieser
fall aufgeklärt wird und ist natürlich
auch total komisches gefühl wenn man
weiß dass diese person der immer noch
frei draußen rum läuft man ja nicht weiß
was dieser mensch sonst nach macht ja
und sich jetzt vielleicht irgendwie auch
in sicherheit fühlen weil er ja bisher
nicht gefasst wurde also das ist schon
sehr komisch für hinweise die zur
ergreifung des täters führen hat die
staatsanwaltschaft berlin eine belohnung
von 5000 euro ausgesetzt
ja und wir wollen tiefer eintauchen in
diesem fall haben unsere achtung
fahndungs experten professor christian
matzdorf ins studio eingeladen ja schon
genommen hermannsdorf schön dass die
zeit gefunden haben sie waren 30 jahre
lang bei der kripo auch hier in berlin
und zehn jahre lang auch im
kriminaldauerdienst das heißt sie waren
oft der erste am tatort wie ist das dann
öffnet man so eine tür und dahinter
liegt dann ein mordopfer ich hatte fast
flip sich jetzt geantwortet so ganz
spontan man kann nicht mehr überrascht
werden wenn man so lange in der
tatortarbeit ist aber das ist natürlich
nicht richtig man lebt immer wieder
dinge wir sind selber persönlich die
sache mit den kindern wenn kinder
geschädigt waren dort immer sehr nahe
gegangen wie erlebt immer wieder dinge
hinter den türen die ein überraschender
fund allerdings nicht vergessen dass
oftmals die kolleginnen und kollegen der
schutzpolizei die ersten sind die dann
eine tür öffnen und segen da ist eine
leiche dass jemand vielleicht umgebracht
worden und dann kommt die kripo schon
mit einer gewissen wie soll ich sagen
vorwarnung an den das ist oftmals dann
der angenehme teil als die überraschung
kann sich wie verarbeitet man sowas
spricht man zu hause mit der familie
darüber ich würde fast sagen man spricht
besser nicht mit der familie darüber so
eindeutig es klingt wenn man muss gute
neutralisation und kombinations
techniken haben also bei mir war das
sport jemand anders kann andere dinge
finden was man nicht machen sollte
rauchen trinken oder seine aggressionen
in anderer art und weise umwandeln ich
bin kein sportler gewesen lange zeit
aber daneben regeln ja man muss irgendwo
die energien fließen lassen ansonsten
zerfrisst senders schon die segel das
ist teilweise sehr schwierig und ganz
auf lasst sie uns aktuell über diesen
fall oxana sprechen wir haben eben
bilder einer überwachungskamera gesehen
die den mutmasslichen täter zeigen was
sagen die bilder aus also da sieht man
eine person vermutlich ein mann kleidet
das mit einer kapuze in dem gesicht
nicht zu erkennen und der läuft sehr
entspannend und ja man hat fast den
eindruck telefoniert er spricht mit sich
beschäftigt sich mit sich selber also
sieht nicht aus wie eine flucht und es
sieht auch nicht aus wie eine person die
sehr unter druck vielleicht unter
anspannung steht ganz im gegenteil sehr
sehr ruhig und entspannend wirken diese
bilder und es wird gute gründe geben
warum die mordkommission hier gesagt hat
das sind bilder die für uns für die
fahndung für die ermittlung wichtig sind
oksana soll mit messerstichen getötet
worden seien und der täter könnte sich
dabei auch selbst verletzt haben was
kann da passiert seien das ist ein ganz
spannender teil wenn sie an einem tatort
kommen sie haben einen menschen die ums
leben gebracht worden ist sie können in
der leiche lesen wie in einem buch also
sie erkennen anhand der verletzung was
passiert ist wieder ablauf der
geschehensablauf war und man kann
natürlich eine leiche auch erkennen ob
die person sich gewehrt hat ob es
abwehrverletzungen gibt ja vielleicht
auch verletzungen von aktiven griffen
möglicherweise einen messer anderen
gegenstand und da spricht vieles dafür
nach dem was wir jetzt hier wissen dass
es eine auseinandersetzung gab das ist
nicht eine überraschung war sondern
tatsächlich dann eine auseinandersetzung
wo das opfer sich noch eine zeit lang
gewährt hat möglicherweise dann auch
spuren blut oder andere dna spuren auf
den realität übertragen hat und auf
seiner hand die tür auch anscheinend
freiwillig geöffnet ja wir wissen nicht
ob es tatsächlich freiwillig war da
müssen wir überlegen also offensichtlich
war sie in dem glauben dass er die
menschen die sie dort einlässt einlassen
kann ohne gefährdet zu sein ob das jetzt
freiwillig war oder ob es eine
vorgeschichte das ist ja auch ein teil
des gegenstandes die ermittlung wir
müssen überlegen das vielleicht vor
beziehung bestanden haben die eine
zwangssituation damm entstehen lassen
vielleicht musste sie jemanden in die
wohnung lassen
herzog wir hoffen alle dass wir diesen
fall aufklären können dass sie diesen
fall aufklären können ich danke ihnen
für diesen besuch heute hier
helfen auch sie den angehörigen und
freunden von oxana homberg helfen sie
der berliner polizei mit ihren hinweisen
die ermittler der achten mordkommission
haben folgende fragen wer die
verdächtige personen am 31 märz 2021 im
bereich des kurfürstendamms gesehen das
opfer hatte zahlreiche verletzungen am
oberkörper vermutlich stichverletzungen
so wie es aussieht hat sich aber auch
ihr killer verletzt als er oxana
homberg/ohm brachte in diesem
zusammenhang fragt die polizei natürlich
ob es auch eventuelle taxifahrer gibt
die in höhe kurfürstendamm 61 ein gast
einstiegen ließen der eventuell blut an
den händen oder auch an der kleidung
hatte hinweise nimmt die mordkommission
unter folgender rufnummer entgegen 030
für berlin
4664 911
888 vielen dank